coppi chi vincerà la sfida di oggi gli
sfidanti di oggi ci sono vi sono pronto
alla sfida contro tutti davvero di
riuscire a battermi vedremo
e voi per chi fate il tifo team alita o
team vitale cream entrano nei commenti
e lasciate un mi piace questo video
perché se questo video raggiunge i 10
mila mi piace ci sarà una seconda sfida
lasciatemi piace mettetevi comodi e che
la sfida che è già primo round ti offro
come scambio un bellissimo popit ananas
ma non solo perché guarda bene anche
nelle bollicine del copit ci sono le
mini amen alcune indichi cosa o ri per
questo bellissimo copit ananas dovresti
saperlo chi che amici che non mi piace
la rana ti offro bel niente
io mi hanno minacciato questo se vuoi
più forti in base a quello che aprì non
puoi premere piota non stai offrendo
niente della loro i premi e basta ok e
me lo tengo io ok non ho capito allora
risi ma non sai cosa ti perdi va beh ti
offre un altro po pt scambio ok io per
questo pulpito multicolor
mi avevi mai visto uno con tutti questi
colori di più c'è un gattino per troppo
carino
che cosa mi aprì per questa
[Musica]
effettivamente questo è carino è tutto
colorato e poi io adoro i gatti quindi
vediamo cosa ti può soffrire una cosa e
tu volevi offrirne quell'anno la su
tutta colorata almeno c'è un anno ma
solo mi avevi detto che non ti
piaceranno
quindi io voglio più pop hit se vuoi il
mio pop hit multicolor
nessun problema allora ti può soffrire i
cupcake e guardavate carino e anche
questo ai mini cupcake all'interno di
ogni pochi beh in effetti quel pop il
caffè che molto carino ma questo a mille
colori quindi va bene ma questo è
l'ultimo altrimenti poi mi riprendo
tutto quindi ti offro una goccia che
potrebbe essere una goccia di pioggia o
una bellissima goccia di rugiada del
mattino celeste ecco qui la mia goccia
se va beh lo dici solo per convincermi
devo pensarci voi lo fareste questo
scambio
questo può più multipla per quei tre
e in effetti sono molto carini a nonché
di daddy quindi ok a
tieni questo pop eater orge e io ho tre
nuovi profit
ho vinto il mio primo focus secondo
round che cosa fino a scambiare io ti
offro qualcosa con i colori arcobaleno
vediamo ma nello specifico è un baleno
allora ti piace l'arcobaleno
che cosa vi offre in cambio e ti do me
che mi piace un sacco perché non ho mai
visto il pop hit arcobaleno eccovelo
chiarito che vediamo ti offro un po pitt
superare c'è un po pitt che si illumina
al buio se non ci credi spegne le
emozioni tra il che si illumina al buio
accetti anzi voglio tenermelo questo
cosa
[Applauso]
no mi ha incantato anche la nato un
bellissimo pochi skirt illumina al buio
non è contento è vero si illumina al
buio e gli all arco bar e all'uomo terzo
round sei pronto perché questo può pitt
è bellissimo ok grillo troppo dello sci
fi confondendone su colori celeste rosa
e giallo e sono tutti i colori pastello
e poi mai visto e coccodrilli pop
interrogatori si dice certo certo certo
certo certo certo certo coccodrillo che
cosa accenti non puoi accettare non mi
ha offerto niente a lotito costruito per
fa l'aspetti aspetta in cambio del
coccodrillo ti offro congelato
buongiorno a forma di gatto che è sempre
stata e perfetto no ma non è un cazzo
quando ti metti ma poi vediamo
mario è un gelato guarda e manda
scrivete nei commenti e un gatto è un
banda mi dispiace ma il mio coccodrillo
più raro quindi non più di più di più
adesso vedo di cosa posso fare allora
ma siccome io lo adoro il coccodrillo ti
offro ben due altri pop hit
ok allora il primo attenzione intenzione
è una farfalla più baleno ti offro a che
ora ricordo che è bellissimo questo mi
dispiace separarmi da questo per odio
offro per il coccodrillo che ne pensi
allora accetti cosa ne pensate
mi sembra che vitali è pronto a darmi
altri compiute per il coccodrillo perché
gli piace tanto quindi proverò a
chiedermi di più
non mi piacciono questi pop hit ma il
coccodrillo in più raro quindi si sono
offerti qua allora quando i miei auguri
no
affare fatto avrei dovuto accettare
prima quarto round cosa le posso offrire
vediamo
attenzione attenzione guarda che cosa ti
offro io ti offro un arcobaleno in
gigante
wow è bellissimo enorme copiarlo tutto
aspetta al momento che proprio un po di
volley lascialo stare cosa offre cambio
wow questo non voglio assolutamente
anche perché adoro i cuori che costerà
tanto allora soprattutto un certo
coccodrillo e vai ma io offro il
coccodrillo che volevi molto bene ecco
quello che volevo di più se io come
convincere evitare che lo rese o ecco un
crollato formato voglio di più
aspetta un grado di più e più mi sta
venendo fame quindi vorrebbe più
colorata che non hai voluto prima guarda
quanti guai sono tratti guarda quanta
grande e quindi non voglio ancora di più
di più
obiettivo i cupcakes non ti fa venire
bava e questo si può vedere molta fame
approccio appoggerà questo quanti sono
dai accetta accetto
a quello che c'era dovete avere tutto
per me quello che mi devi dare il cuore
che devo d'arte sceneggiare il mio cuore
ha detto prima del 5 invece grazie ma io
almeno un po btg galdi ha detto secondo
me è affatto lo scambio migliore in
questo turno io con il cuore gigante un
vitale contanti pop hit ma ora tocca a
me offrire quinto round ti offro un
bellissimo girasole non riferissimo
anche l'immagine del giro sono ma non
solo questo girasole che tocca sacco
aggiungo una crisi a sole mar viola e il
tetti con i rumori pop che fa quindi che
cosa mi offrì per questi tutti la storia
anzi vi offro anche il terzo giro sole
avrei 3 girasoli due gialli arancioni e
un lilla e viola che è casa mia free
quindi che cosa mi offri per questi tre
pochi reggina soli poi questi fanno un
sacco di rumore effettivamente fanno
tanto rumore tantissimi bonfitto
perfetti questo mi piace tanto ma che
questi mi piacciono tanto i progetti nel
giardino a prendere il sole ma che si
faccia sto prendendo il sole
che cosa vi ha spiegato allora ti
offrono ricordo che non è accettato
prima tpu pochi questo bellissimo polipo
pooley questo giallo questa golini sotto
c'è pure gli occhietti vedi video gli
occhietti non sono pochi soprattutto il
resto se o il blu ripete supercar e
inoltre non ritorno
io adoro gli animali il punto debole di
vitale il cibo mentre il mio sono gli
animali
dovrei accettare secondo voi io ti offro
questo bellissimo pesce rosa però che
bello e questi hanno anche giochetti
quindi valgono di più è il pesce è
bellissimo rosa ma anche in poli per
tutte anche lo ricordo voi fareste
questo scambio
ho deciso
[Musica]
certo challenge finita ora deciderete
voi chi ha vinto in base a quali pop hit
vi piacciono di più io ho la bar come
lei chiamata a goccia della secca
unicorno furbetto pesce roca e
soprattutto il mega cuore gigante di
bobby zamora pietra ottenuto vitale i
miei bobbit sono questo qui che è
bellissimo e si illumina a lui ben tre
girasoli do numero due a baa3 e di due
normali e uno celeste viola poi all
cupcake va la fragola con ovviamente
adesso infatti evento che l'antica
agente o milkshake esatto la la nostra
guida del milk shake è la fragola
gigante che bello ma infine è quello più
bello di tutti il coccodrillo
mi piace troppo adoro che ammetto
vittorio perché c'è un po come lo
scrivete nei commenti chi abita la sua
di un mi piace per un altro la città
tenendo il suo padrino di vuole mordere
attenzione
criticare perdetevi i nostri altri video
mordente quella che preferite quella che
preferite abbonato ibra vero